holy [ __ ] DC once again taking notes
from Marvel's playbook like when the age
of Ultron trailer was going to come out
on Monday and then it was leaked online
all right here it is now pretty much the
exact same thing happened with this new
Batman V Superman trailer so the Batman
V Superman trailer has officially been
released online people wanted me to
review the bootleg version but I was
like I don't want to review a version
that's taken from a phone like phone
footage just looks like [ __ ] like I'm
gonna miss something I was waiting for
the real one and now we have the real
one because everyone was talking about
Star Wars and people can't be talking
about Star Wars for too long other
probably still gonna be talking about
Star Wars after this oh this is a bad
trailer it's pretty good trailer trailer
starts out it shows this statue in it's
zooming in on it and of course everyone
now that kal-el is on earth he's public
people have seen what he can do they've
apparently erected a statue in his honor
cuz clearly you know that's what this
thing is and since everyone in the world
has an opinion just like those douche
bags that get on YouTube and talk about
trailers that drop some people are like
oh this is very cool other people will
like well what can he really do is he a
threat his very existence challenges our
place in the universe and you hear Jesse
Eisenberg and he's like now we know
Devils don't come from the ground that
come from the sky and yes even now in
the trailer I heard his voice I thought
of the picture of him while his voice
was being played in the trailer I'm not
gonna talk about it anymore cuz I feel
like I'm beating a dead horse I just I
clearly have to see him in action
I just still don't see it then it pans
around to the Superman statue and it
says false gods spray-painted on his
chest
which I love the fact that this is going
to be a thing in the movement you
imagine if this godlike person just
ended up on earth it's not gonna be out
cut and dry like oh yeah he's our Savior
he's mr. Superman like it was in the
comic book when the comic book first
came out oh man it's gonna be a lot of
people talking about like I don't know
that I like the fact that he's here I
guess there's some Superman tasks for us
all I saw was like these dudes it look
like SWAT team members but they had the
Superman logo on their shoulders now and
they all to him I'm like are you Wow
enough separation of church and state
from whatever government agency they're
a part of is he cool with that is he
like yeah you guys should kneel before
kal-el or is he like get up please some
just a dude I'm from Kansas listen all
the Superman stuff stops and then you
see the bat flick at this point I'm
pretty much on the side of that flick I
think he's gonna be good I know when it
was first announced when Ben Affleck was
gonna be Batman I was like I don't see
it I'm hoping the same thing happens
with Jesse Eisenberg as Lex Luthor I
hope I see enough of him or I'm like no
actually it's good keep in mind I want
that to happen this
moving about Batman versus Superman I
want every element of that to be great I
don't want any facet of a movie that is
Batman vs Superman to suck at all do I
how you hear Jeremy Irons who plays
Alfred in this movie and he's like this
is how it starts that feeling of
helplessness that's what makes good men
cruel he says something like that I
might be paraphrasing but it's
interesting to me that he said good men
cruel not like good men bad like cruelly
who is being cruel in this movie is it a
general thing like crime is up because
Superman came here and so people are
like the world is ending and now they're
just turning to crime and [ __ ] eluding
the break-in windows or is it like
someone is truly cruel is he talking
about Lex Luthor in this movie is he
talking about Bruce Wayne is you warning
Bruce Wayne like hey man you keep
fighting this you're gonna become an
[ __ ] that look looks big is a bulky
looking dude this straight up has the
physique of old Batman from Frank
Miller's The Dark Knight Returns just is
uncanny then the best part which
ultimately anyone who saw the Comic Con
footage already saw this part when
Batman's and his big robotic [ __ ]
Superman outfit Superman is all floating
above them but it does have new dialogue
is the dialogue of people have been
talking about who already saw the
trailer and they're gonna be talking
about this well after today you're
Batman who sounds like jigsaw from Psalm
eezol I told me do you bleed you will
and then bond Batman vs Superman which I
did I'm excited to say that [ __ ] I'm
excited for this for a couple different
reasons I love the realistic take that
Nolan put on Batman for sure but I'm
ready to see Batman come back down to
the comic book point is it was a good
trailer I hate knowing that this trailer
came out today specifically because Star
Wars came out yesterday
you come out with this Batman V Superman
trailer the day after the Star Wars
trailer brakes which he's already
brought in a [ __ ] ton of hits not only
does it feel kind of desperate but it's
just bad timing Batman V Superman came
out during a Star Wars thing I'd have
given it time maybe that's why I don't
work in marketing departments anything
case it was a pretty good trailer I want
to see Batman fight Superman looks like
we're gonna get that unless it's like
told me do you bleed you will kal-el is
like it doesn't need to be this way he's
like you're right let's go fight that
bald [ __ ] I'd probably be kind of
upset at that point though the Batman V
Superman trailer have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you wanna see more click right here
to see more